hello everyone welcome to another
episode of unlocking Lille so I have a
dream to live in a world where we can
all move towards our truest potential
which is what led me to leave my
corporate job to work and mentor under
Evan today we're building a business
around my speaking and coaching and all
of you are invited to join me on my
startup journey so far all of you have
been following my speaking journey I
have spoken at TEDx I've spoken at
congregations and even libraries and I
love it and I have many more coming my
way but I do have another love something
that brings me a lot of joy and
happiness that is being a coach I have
coached hundreds of people in finding
their one word and helping them with
their business and life so today I'm
gonna share with you how I became a
coach so when Evan and I first sat down
to strategize how to move my business
forward one of the things that he
suggested I do was to be a coach and it
was so reluctant about it because I did
not see myself as a coach I saw myself
as a speaker and it was never part of my
plans to that point I've only been
prepping to be a speaker I have done
workshops in front of large groups of
people so doing one-on-one coaching was
something that didn't even cross my mind
until he had mentioned it so I hand and
hard for a bit and eventually I said yes
I said yes because might mean objective
in going on stage and speaking in front
of thousands of people is because I
wanted
be the catalyst to help someone change I
want to be able to show people that they
can live their true potential
so really coaching is no different I
could still do the same thing just on a
one-on-one basis instead of a large
group in addition I get to take some of
the common problems that come up during
my coaching sessions and bring them as
themes unsaved so I could help even more
people so knowing those two things I
took my workshop and I customized it in
such a way that was suitable for a 1o1
coaching session so I set out to do 100
free coaching sessions and the reason
for that is like most new businesses you
want to give out free trials and free
samples to see if people actually like
it and see if it's a good fit for them
but obviously the goal is to provide so
much value in that free trial or free
sample that people have become paying
customers for you and even give you some
referrals so we gifted a bunch of free
sessions via our contests and promotions
and then the day came the day of my
first coaching session ever
I remember feeling so nervous I was like
sweating all over the place in fact I'm
like sweating right now thinking about
it and I was like replaying all of these
like worst-case scenarios over and over
and over again in my mind and I was like
secretly help me I'm like maybe you just
won't show up maybe we'll just cancel
last minute but that's okay it's okay if
he cancels but he did show up not only
did he show up he actually showed up
early and I was really awkward in the
beginning but as the session went on I
became more comfortable I found comfort
in knowing that I can help him so during
a session he expressed to me that he's
an aspiring entrepreneur and he really
wants to start his own business but he's
afraid to leave his job because of his
finances but he also hates his job and
he doesn't want to be there anymore so
during our session we walk through the
one word process he end up discovering
what is what word was and we also
strategize - how to start his business
without risking the finances at the same
time so we ended the call I felt like it
was a great session for me it was a
great session for her and we ended it it
felt great but it wasn't until the next
day when he sent me an update which was
a screenshot of this website that he
started for his own business and there
he featured the products that he wants
to sell and he said that it was all
because of
together and that made me so happy and
it probably so much joy and that joy
brought me some clarity my clarity and
knowing that this is something I really
want to do it really did fill my soul
thinking about it but I didn't want it
to be like a one-off thing I wanted to
get so good that I could become
someone's ongoing coach because I want
to be with them every step of the way I
don't want them to leave after the first
session and not know what's gonna happen
next I want to be with them in their
journey because I know how lonely it can
be to do everything on your own so I
made it a goal to convert every single
free session and provide so much value
that they'll come back and become my
ongoing client and I get to be part of
their journey so I knew in order for me
to have people coming back as my ongoing
clients I just needed to get a lot
better as a coach like a lot better and
I knew it was gonna take time it's
making practice an experience but I also
did not want to wait ten years before I
got there so I decided to really immerse
myself and dedicate myself and become
the best that I can be in the middle
chain so I sped up the process by doing
these following things number one is I
got the help of my mentor Evan so after
every session I would make a list of the
things that
did really well as well as the things
that I needed improvements for so he
would give me suggestions on all the
things that I can compose and every time
he gave me a suggestion I would go back
outside to the next session and again
and again and again and I saw that my
sessions were getting a lot better
thanks to Evan but in addition to that I
also wanted to get a help of external
sources so I started reading books on
coaching I read five books on coaching
and how to make myself better I also did
two online courses to help my coaching
as well I even spent probably a hundred
hours dissecting Tony Robbins do his
interventions to really really focus on
what he's doing really well to see if I
could bring back to my coaching sessions
as well so I did that over and over and
over and over again and eventually after
50 sessions someone asked me to be their
ongoing coach and that made me so happy
like finally it is paying off my goal is
finally coming true but at the same time
I still continue to do my free sessions
and the reason for that is like many
businesses you want to have a steady
flow of new people coming through if you
think about a restaurant they rely
heavily on foot traffic for people to
come in and experience their service and
product and their food do and if people
really like it they'll come back and
become long-term customers and that's
the same for me I wanted new people
coming in and trying my service and
again providing so much value that they
become my ongoing clients so I kept on
doing that over and over and over again
and eventually one ongoing client turned
into two turns in three five
and today I have 15 ongoing clients and
I get to meet with them on a regular
basis to help them with their life and
business and I get to see them change I
get to see them grow after each session
and they give me updates on all the
things that they're doing toward their
mission and it makes me so incredibly
happy and most importantly and I get to
be part of their journey in realizing
what they truly want out of life and
that I don't think there's anything else
that makes me happier than knowing that
I could be part of someone's life in
that sort of way and I feel like I'm
just getting started
so I'm gonna still continue to do what
I'm doing and I'm gonna keep going until
I continue to grow that 15 into 20 into
30 maybe a hundred I don't know but all
I know is I want to continue to help
people and impact the world in a
positive way and the lesson that I
learned from this experience is that you
have to be flexible and open-minded with
your how but be stubborn in your mission
and your why so my mission was to be a
catalyst to help someone change to
really show people what their true
potential is and my how was through
speaking but that didn't really matter
what if it's speaking or coaching it
goes all in line with what my mission is
not only has coaching helped me add
another layer to my speaking when I do
go on stage but has shown me something
that I never even thought of before Evan
had mentioned it it makes me so happy to
be a coach like I love Wednesdays
because I get to be a coach and I get to
meet with my ongoing clients as well as
new clients I loved it so much that I
actually opened up an extra day I gave
up my Saturdays to be a coach because it
makes me so incredibly happy and that
goes to show when you open-minded enough
in your
how in your path you just never know you
might discover something that will give
you incredible joy and happiness and I'm
a special shadow from Melissa O'Brien
Melissa thank you so much for being
there for me since day one and always
writing sweet supportive comments to
help me to keep going
your presence is much much appreciated
finally the question of the day is what
is your dream business write in the
comments below and I'll join in on the
discussion thank you so much for
watching and more importantly being part
of this journey with me it's been seven
months but I feel like I'm just getting
started and I couldn't ask for a better
community than the leave nation to be
part of my journey so thank you so much
again I will see you guys on very very
soon bye bye raise your standard Apple
at the core its core value is that we
believe that people with passion and not
one drop of my self-worth depends on
your acceptance of me i don't ever give
up I'd have to be dead or completely
incapacitated hey believe nation if you
want to see my all-time favorite top 10
most a success I have a very special
secret video for you these are the
individual clips that I have personally
learned the most from and applied to my
life and my business check the link in
description for details